Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday, March 11th:
3 days before I have to turn in the first draft of the Paper Towns screenplay.
*Theme Music*
So Hank, I was going to try to break the Question Tuesday world record today,
but I just don't think I have time. I've got to get back to writing the screenplay.
But the fact that I have no time at all today will not stop me from
answering at least some real questions from real NerdFighters!
Question 1: Where and when is your event in Amsterdam next week?
It's on Thursday March 19th at 7 p.m.
at...Dyaren?
Oh man how am I ever going to immigrate to the Netherlands
when I suck so bad at Dutch?
Anyway, info in the sidebar. Everyone in and around Amsterdam should come.
Also, quick reminder this Friday, I'm doing a fundraiser
for an awesome charity called The Second Story in Indianapolis!
It's $5 bucks if you're a student, $8 if you're aren't. More info in the sidebar
Goose1977 asks "How do I get nerd girls to like me?"
I don't know that's not really my area
of expertise. Hold on, let me get Willy
Hey Willy!
Girls love you Willie! How do you do it?
Kisses?
You lick their ears? I don't think that's the..
I don't.. at least not at first I don't
think that's the way to get it done man.
Why do girls like you? Is it because you pee a lot, or because you bark in the house or
because you make a lot of weird noises?
Wait, is it because you're the silent, shy,
aloof, type? AHHHHH!
The silent, shy, aloof, type doesn't lick me in the mouth when I'm video blogging!
No, I think I can tell you pretty succinctly why girls like Willy. It's because he's a
puppy.
Guys, my first piece of advise about getting girls to
like you: become a puppy.
A kitten would also be acceptable, or
possibly a sneezy panda bear.
goose1977, I've been dumped by a lot of girls.
And in the process of acquiring those broken
hearts I learned one important lesson:
girls don't like it when you get all
creepy stalkery on them.
See the problem with guys is that we're needy, but we're taught that we're not
allowed to be needy. So when we get in a
situation where we're allowed to be
vulnerable
we sorta like rip it open and let the need flow out
and it's kinda disgusting.
I have this theory that girls, at least girls not
named Bella, have this warning system
inside their heads and whenever we get
too obsessed with them and focused on
them it's like beep beeep beep beep back away
back away beep beep beep beep back away!
Which by the way is a totally helpful
warning system, because no girl, or any
other person for that matter, will ever
fill up the holes inside of you!
It's like Chinese finger cuffs. Do you remember
Chinese finger cuffs? The way to get
Chinese finger cuffs off of your fingers
is instead of being panicked and
overeager, just relax.
Oh and one other thing guys, it will be
really helpful if you can see girls as
like people instead pathways to kissing
and or salvation.
one of the things I've noticed over the
years is that if you treat girls like
people, although admittedly people who
like fart jokes somewhat less than the
rest of your friends,
they are much more likely to like you.
Question 3
Hank has song Wednesday but why don't you ever sing? If you watched all of our videos you'll know that at
the end of 2007 I gave the NerdFighters a gift
and that gift was me not singing anymore.
Question 4: Any new hot youtubers?
Oh there are so many, but recent new
favorites include Ransriggs and wheezywaiter
they can be checked out in the sidebar.
NerdFighters, I'm up to 100 peeps so
far but that's nothing! Please keep
donating.
Hank I'll see you tomorrow for song Wednesday and the
next time you see me
I'll be happy dancing in Holland  DFTBA